There's a lovely German word for when you try to make it something better only to make it worse.
I trust you had a fruitful day.
I do not say happy, although I hope it has been happy.
Namo dasa bhagavato arahato sama sambodasa
Namo tassa bhagavato arahato sambha sambuddhasa.
Homage to the Buddha, the blessed noble and fully self-awakened one.
I just want to mention, some of you might not know,
the online meditation hall, which is on the Zoom.
And the times are 6 a.m., nice and early, fresh, 9 a.m., 11 a.m., so that's 6, 9, 11 in the morning, and 2 p.m., 4 p.m., and 6 p.m. in the afternoon.
And in the morning at 6 a.m., Noreen is normally here, and I'm hoping to be here at 2 p.m.
Noreen will also be here now if you want to get on the zoom to stop zoom bombing and all that you have to get in touch with Mark now Mark normally oh there he is there's Mark hi Mark I'm just wondering if you'd like to put your email up so that people can contact you if they want to be on the on the online meditation hall can you hear me Mark are you there
yes no yes no maybe well give it time anyway um so that's uh that's an online meditation or you can join you can go on anytime actually but those are the time set where you might meet people there six nine eleven in the morning and two four six in the afternoon okay
So there we are.
Mark's put it up there.
That's Mark Arthur.
So if you want to take that email, he'll let you in.
He's the gatekeeper.
We don't pay him anything.
So now just to carry on with the foundations of mindfulness, as Bhikkhu Bodhi calls it, is discourse number 10.
It's the jewel of the collection, remember.
And we finished the body part.
So that contained the breathing, of course, the whole instructions on breath meditation, the four postures, standing, walking, sitting and lying down, full awareness, continual awareness during the day, the foulness of the body, which remember is really to do with becoming disenchanted with the body, disinterested with it.
And of course, the good old charnel grounds.
Oh, elements, the elements, the four basic elements that point to where our physicality and mentality meet at the sense door, right?
That's the retina, the eardrum and so forth.
And the nine charnel grounds, yes, the nine bodies that are slowly corrupting into pure dust, to dust thou shalt return.
So the next one is feeling.
Now, I've actually done quite a bit on that already on talk number 28, if you want to look it up.
But we'll read it through and it's pretty straightforward.
And how does how does one abide contemplating feelings as feelings?
Now, remember, he's translating it as feelings.
But to me, the grammar is to feel feelings in feelings.
In a sense, they both mean the same thing, feeling as feeling, feelings in feelings.
But the idea of being right in there, like in a room, you know, in the bath, like you're sunk in.
So whatever feeling that is, the idea is to get into it and really feel it, right?
Open up to it completely, absorb into it, you might say.
Here, when feeling a pleasant feeling, the meditator understands, I feel a pleasant feeling.
Now remember, you're not supposed to be saying to yourself, I am feeling a pleasant feeling.
It's just a recognition that you're feeling a pleasant feeling.
It's a consciousness, right?
You're aware of it.
And when feeling a painful feeling, understand, feel a painful feeling.
When a neither painful nor pleasant feeling, he understands,
that i feel a painful nor neither a painful nor pleasant feeling so there's there's the neutral bit uh actually if you look close enough uh feelings will always shade ever so slightly towards pleasant ever so slightly towards um unpleasant and that's the dual world that we live in right i mean that's apparent to us i think even in the womb that there are pleasant uh feelings and unpleasant feelings
And this whole area that we would call neutral, you see.
And of course, it's upon neutral feelings that we can establish that calmness, that peace.
That's why the breath, walking meditation.
So they do have their purpose in our practice.
And then he knows when there's a worldly feeling, a worldly pleasant feeling and a worldly unpleasant feeling.
and a neither pleasant nor unpleasant worldly feeling.
And it knows when an unworldly feeling is there.
So worldly and unworldly.
So we did this, of course, way back there.
So worldly feelings are just to do with, you know, being in the world.
The sensual world is to do with the work we're doing.
whatever we're experiencing, eating, etc.
Worldly, the unworldly feelings are all to do with the spiritual side.
So it's to do with renunciation, letting go of things with compassion, love, worldly feelings that come through our practice, peacefulness, the factors of enlightenment, equanimity and things like that.
So anything to do with the spiritual life is unworldly.
That's the word for it.
Anything to do with the world is worldly.
That doesn't necessarily mean it's unwholesome.
If you're doing worldly, like the work you're doing, for instance, will have a worldly purpose.
You've got to earn money and so forth.
But it doesn't make it unwholesome, right?
But that doesn't lead to liberation.
What leads to liberation are the investigation of these three characteristics.
Remember how we cause suffering, the process of wrong desire, impermanence and not self.
And there's the usual refrain, he abides contemplating feelings as feeling internally, but he also notices such feelings in other people.
You can tell it on their face and so forth.
And if you're sensitive enough, sometimes you can actually feel how they feel.
If they're joyous, you can feel the joy being mirrored on the surface of your own heart, equally so anger and all that.
And he abides feeling feelings both internally and externally.
He also abides feelings in their arising factors and abides contemplating feelings in their vanishing factors.
and abides both feelings of the arising and falling.
So that's basically being aware that everything is always in process, always consistently changing.
That's the one thing that never changes.
Or else mindfulness there is this feeling is simply established in him to the extent necessary for their knowledge and mindfulness.
And he abides independent.
So this last phrase is really the position of vipassana, where finally you're just resting on the object, observing it very, very carefully.
And there is this background view of it, which is looking at it from the point of view of any reaction that we have to it.
It's impermanence and not self.
It's just a way of looking.
Okay.
And just enough.
He says just enough knowledge.
Actually, the word is just enough intuitive awareness, actually.
Just bare knowledge and mindfulness, bare knowledge and mindfulness.
So it's just that ability to observe with that open curiosity, with the intelligence awakened, right, that intuitive intelligence sort of awake.
And that's just part of that whole of awareness.
Remember, there's the active and the passive.
So the passive is when we're receiving stuff and the active is when we actually grasp what's happening.
Yeah.
First you look and then you see.
And he abides independent, not clinging to anything in the world.
So let go of the world as such.
So that's the whole section on feeling.
Now, it is an important section because if you ask yourself,
If you look into your body, especially feelings that are caused by the mind.
So there are two, this doesn't actually say that, but there are two different types of feelings.
Remember, feelings coming from the body, pain, discomfort, sense of pleasure, itching, all those sorts of things.
And pleasure and pleasant feelings coming from the heart, from mental states.
And when you say you're happy, just ask yourself, what do you mean by that?
Do you mean you have happy thoughts?
yeah or you i mean or is it a sensation or is it more a feeling of being a happy feeling in us do we rate our happiness by how we feel rather than what we're thinking or actually or the physical state if i put something in my mouth which is sweet and uh i mean do i do i say that this is happiness no that's just sweetness but if the sweetness makes me happy and i say oh
I'm happy.
I'm happy because of the sweetness.
And we often judge our lives according to whether we're happy or not.
So if I'm not being happy, I find that I'm wasting my life or I'm finding that my life isn't worth living anymore.
See, so it's important to find that distance from feeling and not to be governed by them, not to personalize them.
There it is.
There is now a happy feeling.
There is now a sad feeling.
Now get on with what you have to do.
As soon as you identify with it, you know, as you say, I am happy, I am depressed, etc.
And in a sense, you've locked yourself in, you know, it's like an imprisonment.
So that's the section on feeling.
The next section is also pretty straightforward, the section on mind or mental states.
So these include both your thinking, your imagining, et cetera, and just general mental states as such of which feeling is part of it, of which the body, of course, comes in somewhere.
So how do you abide with the mind as the mind?
So he understands a mind affected by desire.
He's got lust here, but that's pretty
uh pretty heavy lust and it tends to be around erotic desires but it could be any sort of desire the mind affected by a wrong desire the mind affected by uh hold on understands the mind affected by wrong desire as a mind affected by wrong desire and the mind unaffected by love by wrong desire is alive unaffected by wrong desire so
it's it's also you know recognizing actually when there's no desire in us and how does that feel how does that feel when there's no desire see so it's not only the negative bit or that you know i'm overcome by this desire and whatnot but how does it feel when it finishes when it ends
And the same with hatred, affected by hatred in the mind, unaffected by aversion or hatred.
So again, if we are in an adverse state, when it comes to an end and the aversion passes and the mind is just empty of those sorts of feelings, how does that feel?
So when we begin to experience the heart-mind, I should say heart really,
the heart-mind as a pleasant place to be, excuse me, when we begin to experience directly a heart-mind which is not caught up in wrong desires or some form of aversion or whatever, then of course we tend to go there, we tend to go there.
So remember that we're always caught up with being excited, always trying to exercise a certain emotional mental state.
What's it like when there isn't any there, when it's just a sense of peacefulness, calmness?
And delusion as well, you see, so that's the mind which is perhaps in a sense of doubt, confused.
the next one is a contracted mind so this is much the same it's contracted by uh again uh wrong desires aversions um things like that wrestler sloth sloth and you know wrong sort of tiredness donuts in the head lethargy in the body that's caused by acts of laziness right
So that is a contracted mind, whereas a distracted mind is one that is governed by restlessness.
Minds going all over the place.
Yeah.
Obsessive thinking, that sort of thing.
So you know that it's a case of just knowing what the mind is actually doing, what the heart mind is actually doing.
He understands an exalted mind and an unexalted mind.
So that's to do with the jhanas, really, these absorption states.
So mostly we're not in an absorption state.
He understands a surpassed mind as a surpassed mind and an unsurpassed mind.
So this is, again, just in these absorption states, exalted, unsurpassed.
These are all very high, very refined states of mind.
And the unexalted ones and the surpassed ones are really to do with just the worldly states of mind.
Yes.
And then there's the concentrated mind, of course, and the unconcentrated mind.
So you can see they all shade into each other.
It's just slightly different ways of looking at it.
And then finally, the liberated mind and the unliberated.
That's not to do with final liberation.
That's just to do with the fact that when we're in an insightful mode, then the heart-mind is illusion.
And when we're in a jhana, in a more of an absorbed, concentrated state, then the mind is liberated from hindrances.
Okay.
And he abides contemplating the mind as mind internally and externally.
So you can see these moods and emotions, mental states in other people, can't you?
Even in their body language.
And he abides contemplate the mind again with the arising factors and the vanishing factors.
So it's again always this impermanence, always this impermanence.
And and then finally, just this this is the mental state and the abides independent, not clinging to anything in the world.
So that that that covers the next two sections of a feeling and and the mind itself.
And the next one is the mind objects.
And we'll we'll sort of tackle that tomorrow because that's a whole whole new section.
So
Really, it's just ways of looking at what we're experiencing.
And remember that when we open up to something, say an emotional state, say we're full of joy, there's always that tendency to want to try and develop it.
So we're always looking at that reaction.
See, we're not getting caught up either in the joy or the reaction to it.
And we're just waiting, just watching that process.
That's all, just watching the process and watching that desire to indulge just begin to fade away.
Then we come back to the joy and there's that mental joy, that mental state.
And then you can go into it to find out, well, what's it made of at that sort of basic level?
And how is it affecting the body?
How does the body feel when we're in a state of joy?
Then you can move from those two different levels of perception.
The perception of those four elements, some form of lightness, of warmth, etc.
And then when you come to a next level of perception, you find this warm joy, okay?
And you recognize it as joy.
So there's different ways that you can play around within yourself, just slowly deconstructing things.
And this takes away that sense of solidity.
Right.
And in so doing, unwittingly, of course, we are establishing this position of the observer and it's there that we want to stay as best we can.
OK, that's in the meditation.
Of course, as you begin to absorb, as you begin to become very concentrated in what you're saying, then remember that that
reflexive that reflexive moment of of the of the of the awareness being aware of itself as the observer as the feeler can disappear and with it time of course and when you come out of that you can always say to yourself oh well that was a moment of pure vipassana you might say right that doesn't make the other type of vipassana with with um with the observer impure not at all uh insights are just insights come at any time
so uh you know just uh you know just work with work with what you have that comes up and you just see it as something to investigate constantly awakening that sense of curiosity okay so i think we've uh we've done for this evening and um yes if you uh if you want to there are those times remember i'll just i'll just remember i'll just remind you again
just in case so this is the zoom yeah at 6 a.m yes wonderful time and they also start there's a chanting starts at 10 to 7 and finishes 10 past thereabouts then there's a 9 a.m 11 a.m so it's 9 6 11 and then in the afternoon 2 4 and 6 and of course when you join you stay as long as you want if it's 10 minutes it's 10 minutes if it's a an hour it's an hour okay
so uh hopefully you'll take advantage of this if you're still in firm lockdown you know if you just if it's just you in in a room or in a house so you might want to take advantage of that very good i can only hope my words have been some assistance may you by your fierce determination be liberated sooner rather than later so we can uh begin our practice